joining us now is monster slowly chief
advisor to operation
warp speed he's here to discuss the
vaccine rollout good morning mr slowly a
real turning point
in the last 24 hours you've been working
on this for the last seven months what
does this day mean to you
well listen it's a it's an amazing day
extraordinary achievement by
thousands and thousands of people at
pfizer at bio and tech
in the operation amazing partnership
between
the academic science the basic science
and research that's funded mostly by
taxpayer money
the ecosystem of biotechnology companies
and pharmaceutical industry
and the us government particularly hss
department and the department of defense
a remarkable performance frankly and i
hope
the beginning of the end of this
pandemic it means
a lot to everybody and we're thrilled we
have a first vaccine and many more to
come
we just heard one health official though
say it's going to be hard to imagine
this going off
without a hitch are you confident the
vaccine will get to the states and get
into the right hands
we are as confident as one can be we
have
rehearsed tested did mock deliveries
every single step of the process in
order to make sure
that we understand how it's working we
also have made sure for instance that
the first
2.9 million doses of vaccines are being
distributed over
three year three days sorry in order to
make sure that if there are any
adjustments we can make
we have an opportunity to make them and
of course you know the unknown and
unpredictable may happen
but we're prepared to deal with it as
quickly as we detect it what's your
biggest logistical concern
i think the biggest concern is
accidental loss
of temperature control in a
cold chain based particularly with the
pfizer vaccine
that's really the biggest concern i
think the the last mile
delivery inoculation of the vaccines
into
subjects but i would say regarding the
operation frankly my
biggest concern is the level of
hesitancy in the country right
i really hope we are going to be able to
change that
ultimately when do you expect the
general population to be able to get the
vaccine
so i would say two things there we think
that within the first quarter of the
year 2021 so by the
middle of the month of march we will
have had enough vaccine doses to
immunize
at least a hundred million americans
which is
mostly the high risk group the elderly
and frail
the health care workers the first line
workers and then by the end of the
second quarter of the year
by the end of the month of may or the
middle of the month of june
we would have produced enough vaccines
doses to
immunize the totality of the american
population right
cbs uh has confirmed that president
trump vice president pence
uh and other senior officials will be
offered the vaccine
given the limited supply do you support
that decision
i think all people that are involved in
major direction of the country
frankly uh should be vaccinated and
protected now specifically
each individual they need to deal with
their physicians and and discuss to
to make those decisions those are
numerically very small number of doses
i would also say that frankly one of the
things that allowed the operation to
succeed and go as fast as it did
has been to stay outside of any
political debate
and i will close that conversation
well congratulations i know there's a
there's still a big mountain to climb on
this but congratulations on a
major turning point uh it really is and
it's thank you very much
it's great to see the the vaccine on its
way monster slowly
thanks so much for being with us if i
may yes
yes can i i would like just like to call
on all my fellow americans
to continue to participate as volunteers
in the clinical trials
it's thanks to the 77 000 people that
participated in the clinical trial for
pfizer
and for moderna that we have those
vaccines there are more vaccine trials
ongoing
we know the vaccines work and frankly it
may be one of the fastest way to access
vaccination is to participate in the
clinical trials thank you for
considering that
thank you thank you for allowing me to
say it thanks have a good day